willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung zur
dritten vorlesung über philosophie der
digitalität in der wir uns mit der frage
nach therapies theologie der digitalität
ersten teil fassen werden und zwar genau
genommen mit der frage nach der
bedeutung künstlicher intelligenz und
der inter objektivität wie ich sie nenne
der rolle die künstliche intelligenz in
unserer lebenswelt in der kultur der
digitalität spielt oder auch spielen
sollte das ist so das thema der heutigen
sitzung und es gibt jetzt ein plan die
mich kurz vorstellen wir werden zuerst
einen rückblick geben auf die letzte
sitzung dann werde ich kurz versuchen zu
erläutern was ich unter künstlicher
intelligenz verstehe dieser begriff ist
nicht ganz klar gibt es ganz
verschiedene auffassungen und ich werde
meine auffassung von anderen theorien
künstliche intelligenz versuchen
abzugrenzen
dann werde ich mich mit künstlicher
intelligenz und inter objektivität
befassen was genau unter inter
objektivität zu verstehen ist werde ich
auch noch genauer erläutern und zum
schluss werde ich eine vorschau auf die
nächste vorlesung geben in der es auch
wieder um die psychologie der
digitalität gehen wird jetzt erstmal zum
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung ich
hatte dort von einer kultur der
elektrizität gesprochen die ich der
kultur der digitalität gegenüber
gestellt habe das ist eine ganz
interessante entwicklung die wir
beobachten können dass hier neue
technologien neue kulturen initiieren
und gewissermaßen hervorrufen und daher
gibt es eine gewisse parallele zur
kultur der elektrizität aber eben auch
verschiedene unterschiede auf dich auch
noch kurz zusammenfassen eingehen möchte
dann hatte ich etwas zum begriff der
neuen medien gesagt hat ja auch was zu
kritik der neuen medien gesagt und am
ende auch eine eigene kritik der kritik
der neuen medien formuliert was man auch
einen meter kritik der neuen medien
nennen könnte jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
zur kultur der elektrizität was ist
darunter zu verstehen gibt es ein neues
buch von tristan das hat den tisch geht
das intensive leben eine moderne
obsession die wird beschrieben wie
bereits im 18 jahrhundert diese neue
technik das neue phänomen die
elektrizität das denken auch bestimmt
hat die kultur transformiert hat ist
natürlich dass vitalisierenden moment
ganz zentral aber auch schon als
teenager philosophie ist vor diesem
hintergrund durchaus zu verstehen
die kultur der digitalität ist ein buch
das hat felix stalder geschrieben da bin
ich jetzt auch schon ein paar mal darauf
zu sprechen die kultur der digitalität
meint dass die digitalisierung nicht
mehr nur ein technologisches phänomen
ist was uns gewissermaßen fremd wie ein
objekt gegenübersteht was zudem der
keinen wirklichen zugang erlangen können
sollen die digitalisierung wird immer
mehr teil unserer lebenswelt sie ist
gewissermaßen das ganz normal ist es
ganz natürlich ist und vor dem
hintergrund eines solchen verständnis
können wir auch mit guten gründen
gegenwärtige medien kritiken der neuen
medien zurückweisen und das habe ich
auch in der letzten sitzung gemacht
darauf bin ich aber noch auf das buch
von marshall mcluhan berg galaxie
eingegangen der eben sagt es gibt immer
wieder neue galaxien die durch
technologische innovationen
hervorgebracht werden wie zum beispiel
dem buchdruck das ist eine solche
galaxie oder dann können wir auch sagen
eine revolution und dann hat er noch ein
interessantes buch geschrieben über
understanding die extensions auf man
hier sieht man verschiedene interessante
symbole in dem er die these vertreten
hat dass das medium nicht nur so eine
vermittlungsinstanz ist so ein bote also
zwischen sender und empfänger vermittelt
sind dass medien eine eigene firma tiefe
realität haben die man als die
erweiterung des menschen verstehen kann
hier zeichnet ersten titel
verschiedenen medien aus unter anderem
das nicht unter anderem das telefon das
sind natürlich noch nicht die neuen
medien von dem wir und auch diese
vorlesung
handelt
man lässt sich diese entwicklung der
neuen medien hat sich auch einen
medienkritik etabliert und formiert die
stimmen bestärkt die für ein post
digitales zeitalter argumentieren hier
ist dieses bild sehr viel sagen das
smartphone verdummt das smartphone lenkt
den blick von den wichtigen dingen weg
ich darf noch mal an die kritik von
manfred spitzer erinnern der die these
vertritt dass das internet nicht so sehr
einen handlungsraum ist wie ich jeden
zum beispiel die stimme sondern dass das
internet eine sucht quelle ist die
potenzielle gefahren psychischer
psychiatrischer natur ausstrahlt und
würde ihn hier in der tendenz
widersprechen es gibt sicherlich
gefahren die von dem internet ausgehen
aber gefahren gehen von allen medien aus
und internet immer mehr teilen unsere
lebenswelt insofern sollten jetzt nicht
zu dramatisieren oder
psychologisieren oder pathologie sieren
wie es später tut ich glaube also wir
müssen die neue medienkritik kritisieren
und zwar deswegen weil sie einen
verkürzten medien begriff der neuen
medien sich zugrunde legen ein medien
begriff der immer noch so sehr auf die
paradigma des vermittelnden ist und was
es nicht schafft das neue medium als
realität der eigenen art wie ich dann
argumentieren wird in eine virtuelle
realität ernst zu nehmen die schon seit
einiger zeit
teil unseres alltags ist und eigentlich
da ziemlich problemlos
genutzt werden kann und vielleicht sogar
auch in ihren medialen charakter
verlieren darüber soll eben auch die
vorlesung gehen das heißt man muss wenn
man eine philosophie der digitalität
entwickeln möchte sich zunächst auch mal
mit der medienkritik kritisch
auseinandersetzen das haben wir letzten
sehr zugetan nicht nach oben rechts in
youtube noch mal den link zu dieser
sitzung ein
so jetzt geht es aber um das eigentliche
thema der heutigen sitzung nämlich um
künstliche intelligenz im rahmen einer
philosophie der digitalität wie gesagt
von digitalisierung unterschieden werden
muss zunächst mal müssen wir feststellen
dass der begriff der künstlichen
intelligenz unklar es ist nicht klar was
künstlich hier bedeutet und dass
intelligenz bedeutet das ist einfach ein
problem das viele forscher den forschern
nicht angehen sie sprechen gleich so
davon als gäbe es da irgendwas
intelligentes was künstlich sein ich
glaube wir müssen zunächst klären was
künstlich und was intelligenz bedeutet
es gibt nämlich verschiedene in
bedeutung dieser wörter bedeutet
künstlich so viel wie eine simulation
ist als ein modell der menschlichen
intelligenz oder bedeutet künstlich so
viel wie da wird eine neue intelligenz
erschaffen in dieser phase die menschen
intelligenz dupliziert also hier gibt es
alles was vergleichbar ist mit der
menschlichen das ist so die frage und im
heer ist diese unterstütze zwei
verständnis von künstlich unterscheidet
man auch zwischen starker und schwacher
kann also die schwache künstliche
intelligenz wäre so viel wie eine bloße
simulation der menschlichen künstler
willi gästen viel zu kurz greift dann
starke kannst nicht intelligenz wäre so
was wie eine duplikation dem
entschließen diese kennt vielleicht
sogar auch ein übertreffen den menschen
intelligenz wir haben jetzt in der
neuesten technischen entwicklung zwei
ansätze es gibt diese wohl verarbeitende
künstliche intelligenz und die
künstliche intelligenz die auf
neuronalen netzen oder den maschinellen
lernen passiert meine these ist das gibt
der zweite ansatz der von den
künstlichen neuronalen netzen ausgeht
der philosophisch interessanten ansatz
ist obwohl auch die symbol verarbeiten
die künstliche intelligenz die stärkung
von regeln ausgeht und logischen
schlüssel die natürlich auch eine
gewisse nähe zur logik pathologischen
operationalisierung obwohl die auch ihre
erfolge hat glaube ich dass der zweite
ansatz auf den ich im rahmen der
heutigen sitzung noch näher eingehen
wertet der philosophisch interessantere
ist und deswegen wird auch nur darauf
konzentrieren so jetzt möchte ich mal
erstmal verschiedene viele
problematische position gegenüber
künstliche intelligenz identifizieren
und dann gemeinsam zurückweisen so wie
ich auch verschiedene positionen
bezüglich der digitalisierung zu beginn
der ersten vorlesung zu den ich auch
nach oben rechts an den kein machen
damals zurückgewiesen hatte die klauten
jetzt ganz ähnlich zunächst mal die
ideologisierung von künstlicher
intelligenz im rahmen einer trans mannis
tisch foto logischen silicon valley
ideologie dann die damit verbundene
anthroposophie sierung der künstliche
intelligenz oder der robotik dieser als
eine lebendige person versteht lesen die
banalisierung von künstliche intelligenz
als bloßes hilfsmittel das heißt als
technologische reduktion und es gibt
noch eine position die traumatisierung
von künstlicher intelligenz als zu
bekämpfen die fade mord moderne das
heißt als ideologische gegenposition zur
ersten position so jetzt kommen wir auf
die geschichte der künstliche
intelligenz zu sprechen die auch ganz
interessant ist
zunächst ist alan turing zu nehmen und
sein sogenanntes in italien game dann
ist ein wichtiger philosophen diesem
kontext john searle und sein sogenanntes
chain east room and dann kann man noch
robert dreyfuss nennen sind jetzt lange
nicht alle der eine interessante
lebensphilosophische analyse von
künstlichen genf vor dem hintergrund
seines phänomenologischen verständnis
entwickelt hat wir müssen uns dann
fragen die künstliche neuronale netze
auf die wir uns ja hauptsächlich kunst
konzentrieren funktionieren und jetzt
gehen wir auf den ersten denken das ist
eine touring und er hat im jahr 1950
einen ganz interessanten aufsatz
geschrieben wie heißt computing
machinery and intelligence
momentan und gewissen semester machen
andere sind da an in kooperation mit der
eth zürich und da haben wir uns auch mit
touring ausführlicher befasst nicht nach
oben rechts ein link zu dieser sitzung
so hier gibt es jetzt ein paar zentrale
zitate die ich mal vorlesen möchte er
sagt jetzt in diesem text von 1950
registered under the better question
to replace bei
der computer which would you well in die
mädchen-gang touring möchte also die
frage kommt maschinen denken können
nicht direkt beantworten warum das
müssen wir noch dahinter stand lassen er
sagt wir sollten diese frage ersetzen
durch eine andere nämlich können
digitale computer in einem spiel was er
noch genauer das schreibt den
sogenannten imitieren
stationsspiel so gut funktionieren wie
es menschen können also können sie sich
so gut verhalten das heißt liegt schon
seine art die heavy juristische ansatz
zugrunde der künstliche intelligenz er
nach dem verhalten dann ist doch mal ein
zitat wir ritschel question kämmerchen
think the left to make nice to discuss
the mentalist believe that the end of
this entry in new south wales general uk
top manager so much and you will be able
to think of me thinking with the
expected to be connected
willi förderndes no use for papers ist
selbst bei consulting teams berlins der
popular jupitz ein test passiert in
aqaba mit van well ist herr to werle
stepmap gegen in franz penny an groove
connection is taken beweidet
klitschko facts and which are
contractors know how can we soundchecks
auf great importance and space news 51
aufbessert also erklärt ihr dass im jahr
2000 nämlich 50 jahre nach der
publikation seines aufsatzes diese frage
ob maschinen denken können viel
selbstverständlicher
wird und vielleicht sogar auch bejagt
werden kann und hier ist noch ein
interessanter punkt dafür sagt
vermutungen connectors sind gar nicht so
blöd wir sollten also immer ein bisschen
vermutung anstellen auch wenn sie
sicherlich nicht in bloße spekulation
hinten dürfen sondern wir sollten
vermutungen und begrifflich arbeit oder
automatisch arbeit immer in einer
gewissen einheit sehen nur so kommen wir
voran und ich denke dem ist zuzustimmen
das künstliche intelligenz andere der
zweite denke auf den ich kurz eingehen
möchte ist schon sehr und sein buch my
friends in science aus dem jahr 1984 in
dem sich ein kapitel befindet mit dem
titel camp computers inc und auch hier
war mache ich wieder oben rechts die
linke zu dieser sitzung die sache mit
der eth zürich
veranstaltet habe in der wir uns auch
mit intensiver befasst haben gibt es
jetzt ein paar zentrale zitate nicht
vorlesen möchte erstmals in jackson ist
nach fischen fröschen text digital
computers in sofia
computers heft bei definition es sind
allein ist die tat mehr als novelle das
system kennt gap von texturen semantic
das zitat ranking ist man just make
money parade in der
cineworld meaningful semantic content
semantic content award winning bei green
und zum schluss konnte sports fehlings
motions und orgel rest of more than a
santa cruz features bei definition der
computer ist unable to the
capability to see mir ist ganz zentral
unterscheidung zwischen syntax und
semantik
syntax ist dasjenige was mit regeln und
symbolen zu tun hat das ist sozusagen
der symbolische war der symbolische
ansatz von künstlich den games logische
schlüsse das ist die syntax regeln und
bedeutungslose symbol davon
unterscheidet soll die semantik also im
bereich des bedeutsamen oder auch wie er
dann analysieren sagt dass mentalen und
er vertritt die these dass wir von der
syntax von operationen logischen art mit
symbolen nie auch wenn sie noch so
komplex sein sollten zudem an tischen
behalten gelangen können das heißt
dadurch dass computer nur symbolisch
operieren nach gewissen regeln können
sie die bedeutung erlangen tja das ist
eine starke these und hier unten haben
wir nochmal diese unterscheidung
zwischen simulation und duplikation
surfer die these dass künstliche
intelligenz menschlichen lebens immer
nur simulieren aber nie duplizieren oder
realisieren kann
ganz wichtiger ansatz man hat
ja soll hierdurch dass auch viele dinge
vorgeworfen aber ich finde diese
unterscheidung zwischen syntax und
semantik s10 sie entscheiden am ende
diese unterscheidung auch die schlüssel
unterscheidung davon möchte ich zum
schluss dieser kurzen geschichte der
künstler intelligenz dieses
geschichtlichen ab wenn sie nur auf
diesen denke eingehen dass es robert
dreyfuss hier auf einem foto von einem
meister kurz an der lmu münchen im jahr
2011 und über dreyfus hat ein buch
geschrieben
und auch ein aufsatz der den titel trägt
megamind erstes model in the brain
artificial intelligence becker brennt
und zwar geht es hier um die frage wie
sich am künstlichen titels zu unserem
gehirn verhält und der frage ob wir ist
modellieren können er hat verschiedene
bücher geschrieben unter anderen ein
ganz frühes mit dem titel kommentierte
fischer intelligence dann ein sehr
bezeichnet titel eines buches mit dem
titel what computers kann the limits of
artificial intelligence von unserer 72
unter noch ein weiteres buch
bordcomputers il canto kritik auf
politische wesen auch hier mache ich
wieder oben rechts den link zur
entsprechenden sitzung in kooperation
mit der idee an zürich an meine ganzen
der seite
neben notiz eine anekdote ist dass er im
jahr 1967 als erster mensch überhaupt
gegen einen schachprogramm verloren hat
in ein schadprogramm das gegen ihn in
schach gespielt hat also so führt auch
die seine kritik natürlich kann man sich
jetzt fragen ob schachspielen eine
intelligenz leistung ist aber ich denke
durchaus dass man sie als solche
bezeichnen können in diesem ausschuss
making gemeint war das model mit brain
hatte noch ein ganz zentrales zitat am
schluss er sagt ich heiligen
wittgenstein arbeit cubase for much more
touristik dem netz intelligence heißt
die modewelt bei peters ist in die orgel
sind eingeholt picked up by die
organistin firmen gering culture in der
mail an alles ist
organisiert inter holt
aktuelles programm computer still have a
very long way to go die kritik also an
sowohl dem symbolischen ansatz als auch
an dem neuronalen netz ansatz ist der
dass sie nicht eingebettet sind eine
lebensbild und dadurch eben nie an dem
menschlichen intelligenz grad und
entstehende die ganz heran gekommen weil
die eben immer mit kooperiert die sie
auch aus kontexten bezieht des
alltäglichen lebens und einen solchen
holistischen ansatz der als aufs ganze
geht und nicht nur details betrachtet
den schreibt eben martin heilige und den
späten nur die wittenstein
und so ist auch sein master um
intelligenz zu betrachten jetzt haben
wir schon ein paar mal hier geredet über
künstliche neuronale netze die ich mit
kein ins abkürzen folgenden was ist das
eigentlich
ich möchte hier nicht genauer darauf
eingehen weil das eine frage ist die
technikerinnen und techniker die
informations wissenschaftlerinnen und
informations wissenschaftler vor allem
beantworten können nur so viel ein
schönes bild hier eine skizze aus
wikipedia was ist damit gemeint ist gibt
eben verschiedene schichten in einem
solchen netz das ist ein bisschen dem
menschlichen gehirn nachgebildet ist es
ein gewisses modell natürlich viel zu
allgemein es gibt
verschiedene eingangs schichten von
neuronen das sind also alt ein einzelner
entitäten die gewisse inputs bekommen
auch outputs geben und diese neuronen
befinden sich miteinander in beziehung
alles ist miteinander vernetzt bei
diesen künstlern machen sitzen und es
gibt input und gibt es verarbeitende
schichten die also nicht der output
schicht sind und diese zwischenschichten
da spielt sich ziemlich viel ab und
deswegen ist auch ein problem bei
künstlichen einsetzen dass man gar nicht
so genau weiß was da eigentlich passiert
weil man gibt nur ein input dann gibt es
diese ketten mails diese verborgenen
schichten dazwischen da passieren ganz
viele vernetzungen eingangssignale
ausgangssignale änderungen der
verknüpfung und dann kommt was raus und
das ist alles so ein bisschen was mit
black box und hier haben wir so viele
philosophen auch andere wissenschaftler
in wissenschaftler große probleme damit
dass man das nicht so ganz
nachvollziehen kann was da eigentlich
passieren das ist jetzt aber glaube ich
nicht so sehr das entscheidende für die
heutige sitzung sind die heutige sitzung
ist interessant dass es ein input gibt
ein output gibt und dass die künstliche
neuronale netze die möglichkeit haben
den output wieder einzuspeisen in den
input das heißt es gibt es eine art
rückkopplung die man auch beck
kooperation nennt das heißt es
künstliche neuronale netz kann immer
mehr sich einspielens kann lernen es
kann sein output vergleichen mit einem
sollwert und kann dann immer mehr sich
bessern dem ist dann versucht seine
fehler zu korrigieren und sich immer
besser anzupassen auf einen gewissen
zweck den man dem netzwerk vorsitzt und
diese reflexive sage ich jetzt mal
struktur das also immer wieder etwas für
eingespeisten sich selbst das macht
dieses system sehr sehr interessant als
eine ganze dementiere form von
selbstbezüglichkeit ist und so erreichen
künstliche neuronale netz erstaunliche
leistungen dieses programm alpha gros
von dem sie vielleicht schon gehört
haben von google das hat es geschafft
den besten golfspieler zu schlagen und
go ist ja ein spiel war es noch viel
komplexer als schach ist und dieses
programm hat geben sich selbst gespielt
und so die regeln perfektioniert ingo
dann ist also extrem der eindruck das
habt ihr es den letzten jahren gezeigt
wie leistungsfähig künstliche neuronale
nutzen ziehen
[Musik]
ja und jetzt möchte ich vor diesem
hintergrund kurz auf den begriff der
inter objektivität eingehen den ich ja
in dezent und dieser vorlesung gestellt
habe
künstliche intelligenz und eben auch
neuronale netze werden immer mehr teil
unserer lebenswelt dann griff der
menschen dass eine interaktion der da
häufig auch dafür verwendet wird zur
computer erscheint dafür nicht mehr
angemessen zu sein weil jede künstliche
intelligenzen mehr teil unserer
lebenswelt wird und gar nicht mehr so
sehr und im sinne eines objekts wenn
überhaupt oder objekts wie es meistens
gefastet entgegensteht ki ist nicht in
meinen augen angemessen als ein subjekt
zu verstehen und zwar deswegen weil wir
dann so eine art roboter vor augen
hätten einen künstler intelligenten
roboter oder eine neubildung des
menschen vielleicht sogar über
menschliches wesen was uns übertrifft
das halte ich wieder zu sehr für eine
spekulation wir sollten es aber auch
nicht banalisieren oder reduzieren auf
ein bloßes objekt warum weil das objekt
uns dann immer gegenübersteht als etwas
schwer vermittelbar ist und so bekommen
wir auch genetische art wie wir mit
diesem phänomen umzugehen haben wenn sie
uns immer als etwas fremdes
gegenüberstehen deswegen argumentiere
ich das wird dass die künstliche
intelligenz immer verstehen sollten vor
dem hintergrund der leistung die dadurch
erzielt wird also von den prozess der
intelligenz leistung und diese
intelligenz leistung die längste zeit
ohne probleme jenseits von subjektivität
objektivität in unserer lebenswelt
nämlich dies wäre der digitalität
integrieren und mit anderen menschlichen
operationen oder intelligenz leistung
vernetzen das heißt das ziel sollte sein
künstliche intelligenz einzubeziehen in
unsere lebenswelt und das passiert schon
im kleinen wird aber natürlich immer
noch mehr zu
und jetzt gibt es interessante tatsache
dass nämlich künstliche neuronale netze
ich nenne nur als beispiele dieses
sprachprogramm
[Musik]
da mache ich auch nochmal eigenen in
einer sitzung dazu
passiert aufgemalten gigantischen
datenmengen
entscheidend ist aber dass diese
datenmenge ich irgendwas extrakt das
sind was irgendwie
ja etwas was mit uns gar nichts zu tun
hat sind diese daten stammen von uns das
heißt wir sind da immer enthalten in
diesen datenmengen wenn auch nicht mehr
individuell bar oder so aber wird jeder
von uns trägt zu diesen datenmengen zu
bei und
das heißt wenn die künstliche neuronale
netz auf diese datenmengen zurückgreifen
dann greifen sie immer auch auf teile
von uns zurück auch wenn das nicht mehr
genau ideen in dem millionär bar ist
aber ist es zumindest nichts fremde
objektiv ist sondern da sieht man schon
dass geht ineinander über das wird in
einer intakten das heißt menschliche
leistung und karl haist interferieren
auf eine weise die vielleicht nicht mehr
im einzelnen genau glück für bar- oder
rekonstruierbar ist wo bin ich jetzt am
ende das ist nicht mehr möglich aber wir
sind dennoch darin damit verbunden und
das finde ich ein ganz wichtigen zugang
zu künstlich delhi genc das ist kein
subjekt was uns da irgendwie mal
überflügelt es ist kein objekt kann die
große maschine die uns nichts weiter
angeht es ist kein blues technologisch
sondern es ist eine realität die
lebenswelt bedeutsam ist ein wichtiger
punkt ist auch noch das künstliche
neuronale netze durch versuchen irrtum
operieren das heißt sie korrigieren sich
selbst
sie erlangen auch eine form von wissen
würde ich sagen indem sie nämlich ihre
gewichtung also die einstellung
innerhalb des netzes diese modifikation
so anpassen dass
das netz funktioniert das der
erzielt erzielbare zweck erreicht das
ist praktisch der effekt oder das ziel
der lernleistung ist eine austarierte
vernetzung zu haben die mit gewissen
operation
funktioniert und das sind die sitzungen
gewichte und wenn die richtig
eingestellt sind dann kann man durchaus
davon sprechen dass das künstliche
neuronale netz wissen erlangt hat von
seinem zweck entscheidend ist jedoch
dass dieser zweck und das ziel und mir
ein bild zu erkennen dann musste zu
erkenntnissen oder auch ein text zu
ersetzen dass der dem neuen online jetzt
immer von außen vorgegeben sein muss
dass neuronale netz verfolgt von sich
aus keinen speziellen ziel das heißt die
künstlichen neuronalen netzes sind nur
hypothetisch autonom also nur unter
einer bedingung autonom die wir eben
diesen netzen geben und das ist wieder
in meinen augen einen grund künstliche
neuronale netze nicht ganz als autonomes
effekte anders sehen und schon gar nicht
als irgendwelche super intelligenten
person
wenn wir jetzt auf künstliche
intelligenz nicht mehr nur subjekt oder
objekt theoretisch sondern wie ich
versucht habe die zweite operation store
ethisch reflektieren so wird es möglich
neuronale netz künstliche intelligenz
jenseits von simulation als wertlose
modellierung oder duplikation im sinne
dieser staaten im steam virtueller
realität zu verstehen virtuelle realität
heißt künstliche intelligenz ist
tatsächlich intelligent aber eben auf
eine ganz andere weise als menschliche
intelligenz und da sehen wir daran dass
künstliche intelligenz nicht mehr diese
genau nachvollziehbarkeit es sitzt wir
wissen nicht was mit diesen verborgenen
schichten den so genannten mittel hätten
erst vor sich geht das muss uns aber
auch gar nicht interessieren wenn wir
sie immer in einem theologischen kontext
betrag
den wir vorgeben das heißt wir sollten
künstliche intelligenzen jedes objekt
just im sinne der inter objektivität
verstehen in der objektiven temp
bedeutet dass wir in eine verbindung zu
diesen netzen treten nicht als gegner
sondern
auf unsere zwecke alles auf die object
sozusagen auf die objektive die wir
herausfinden möchten das heißt in der
objektivität bedeutet einen kontext von
gründe und ziele von objectives der
durch künstliche intelligenz weiter
vernetzt und verstärkt wird jetzt kann
man sich natürlich fragen wird zur
künstliche intelligenz als ein
hilfsmittel gebraucht es geht sicher
nicht in diese richtung wo ist eben
entscheidend und künstlichen neuronalen
netzen dass die nicht wie ein objekt
vorliegen sind die sind eben auch
wiederum ihrerseits vernetzen wie können
sie gar nicht mehr so klar
identifizieren das ist wieder dieser
punkt der vernetzung der in der
digitalität herrscht deswegen glaube ich
können wir es durch außenseiter in die
objektivität verstehen jetzt habe ich
hier ziemlich viel abstraktes gesagt und
möchte das in der nächsten sitzung am 19
november noch genauer ausführen und zwar
diesmal komplementär auch wieder eher
psychologisch betrachtet diesmal unter
dem begriff der trans subjektivität die
nicht den begriff der in die
objektivität komplementär ergänzen das
seite gesehen möchte und dazu möchte ich
mich verändert das internet
konzentrieren was ist damit gemeint
damit meint dass mehr als subjekte
unsere mentalen gehalte unsere
persönlichen gehalt immer mehr vernetzen
mit anderen zu checken und so entsteht
ein kontext dem man eben gerade hinter
objektivität nennen könnte der aber
unter dem gesichtspunkt der
subjektivität als trans objektivität
bezeichnet werden kann das heißt wir
treten immer mehr als subjekte mit
anderen objekten eine verbindung so dass
wir eigentlich und subjektivität
überschreiten weil alles subjektive
plötzlich mit anderen subjektiven
unmittelbar durch das internet vernetzt
so dass nämlich trans zur aktivität
diesen begriff möchte ich genau erklären
anhand des internets dass ich nicht nur
als ein neues medium versteht sind
ebenfalls ein handlungsraum in diesem
sinn jetzt erstmals eine vernetzungs
raum der subjektivität ganz neu fassen
lässt und das ist ja auch eine frage die
uns aus theologischer perspektive
betrifft ich werde auf das internet dann
nochmal auf folgenden sitzung genauer
eingehen wenn ich es dann unter
ethischen gesichtspunkten
einen handlungsraum als einen virtuellen
handlungsraum näher bestimmen vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit und bis zur
nächsten sitzung